what opportunities came to the two of
you from Sundance that probably would
not have happened had you not shown
there same with the Independent Spirit
Awards well film independent I went
along and did the producers program at
film independent which was a great
experience and then right on the heels
of that I did the film producers weekend
long weekend up at the Sundance ranch up
in Sundance itself they invited me there
and that was a great experience because
I got to meet some of my you know heroes
as far as producers and filmmakers are
concerned because they were a part of
Sundance alumni to come and give you
know talks and help you figure out
certain aspects about producing and that
was that was a great experience to have
that and that wouldn't have been
available to me it would have been
available but it wasn't I wasn't an
invitee yeah as a result of as a result
of up solidia at Sundance I was invited
to these things which was great and then
Ashland Film Festival which is in
Southern Oregon
it's run by Jo Ann Feinberg and she our
film went there and won the festival and
Jo Ann invited us the following year to
be selectors for the program in the jury
to be on the jury and that was a great
experience as well that's an amazing
film forth and it's amazing Film
Festival was obviously like when you if
you're so accused to have a film at
Sundance a lot of doors do open you know
and without a doubt I think it you know
it's that thing like it
it gave us a certain level of validation
you know with what we were doing and I
was selected to attend
sundown screenwriters lab which was
phenomenal and was working in another
film we did have a little break we had a
baby so that that took us out of the
circle a little bit but um you know also
I made I've just made my second film I
have no doubt of course the it was
because of obsolete eeeh that I was able
to have that opportunity to make a
second film which is a much bigger
budget there's no way I would have you
know been given that opportunity if I
hadn't already directed a film and also
I think director one you know that did
reasonably well so I think I mean just
going as soon as we met so many people
our world sort of expanded so much we
felt I think one of the beautiful things
with Sundance particularly you really
feel part of a community there's a
feeling of like being part of this sort
of family and it's a beautiful family to
be in where they really nurture and help
the people within it you know you got
people who run that you know who run the
Institute people like Michelle sadder or
you've got you know you've got John nine
or you know Sheree or any of the
programmers in Trevor Groff that they
had at the table they're organizing the
programmers I mean these are just all
very passionate people about artists and
storytellers and so you can't help but
be affected by their enthusiasm when
they invite you to come along to that
party you're like oh my god this is
amazing
you know as a result I mean definitely I
feel like so I mean there were like a
myriad of opportunities you know I had
other writing jobs since then which
again wouldn't have happened had I not
had this film and without it now it was
like it was a combination with being at
Sundance a couple one review in
particular that was very favorable to
the film Todd McCarthy yeah which you
know I think that was something that it
turned a lot of heads and really got me
a lot of meetings and and helped me
progress with my work yeah but that was
that was really it really opened a lot
of like Diane said it really expanded
our film world community and from there
we went on to meet other really
enthusiastic filmmakers and
you know still stay in touch with them
to this day you know
you